the party of President Lincoln is now
the party of mr. Cruz and mr. Trump
young how come well there are lots of
reasons but here I'm going to go back to
a subject about which I right it's not
the only reason the only reason but an
important part of that story is the race
story in the 19th century and Ferb the
first half of the 20th century um the
white man's party was a democratic party
certainly in the South the white man's
Bernie was a democratic party when the
dim when the Democratic Party opened up
to black people switch especially in the
south the race story is an important
part of why the party of Lincoln has
become the party of Trump and Cruz how
come that race still met us in American
politics that much well there was a
European writing in the 1830s who wrote
one of the most incisive analyses of
American democracy that exists Alexis de
Tocqueville democracy in America he then
in the United States you had the
crossing of two things you have on the
one hand you have slavery and it was
racial slavery so de Tocqueville said
that even even when slavery is abolished
there will be this memory the white
people and the black people will know
who the slaves once were even after
slavery is abolished the black people we
will know that their forebears were
slaves and he thought that this was
really the poisoning
of the possibility of racial justice in
America I don't think that de
Tocqueville was correct I tend to be an
optimist about this but look I hate he
coach no not to tinys decodes is is in
the pessimistic tradition he would say
de Tocqueville was right not only would
he say it you know Malcolm X would have
said de Tocqueville was right my former
colleague here Derek Bell would have
said de Tocqueville was right my father
would have said de Tocqueville was right
I come from different tradition in the
19th century the great spokesperson from
the tradition that i follow would be
Frederick Douglass Frederick Douglass
even before the abolition of slavery was
once asked do you see a time when there
will be racial justice racial equality
in America and he said yes in the 20th
century of course Martin Luther King jr.
in the 21st century Barack Obama now the
people who follow de Tocqueville are not
stupid people there is a reason to think
he's got a strong argument and of course
it's tragic that that argument is
plausibly them it's plausible I don't
think it's ultimately correct but it's
certainly plausible and you know we'll
see